is the mac studio really that much
better than the imac and imac pro that
it replaces well today we will find out
once and for all i will be comparing
both the base model and the mid spec 4
000 m1 ultra against our five thousand
dollar imac pro and our thirty five
hundred dollar i9 5700 xt imac that we
tested out and reviewed that way we
could see if apple is actually ripping
us off having a separate mac and then
having to buy a 1600 studio display
along with a full keyboard and a mouse
which were previously included in
apple's all-in-one imac system we're
going to take a look at benchmarks
different power usages and a bunch of
real world testing with real world
applications and i think you guys will
be surprised now jumping right into it
we're gonna take a look at the single
core performance with geekbench and you
see there is a huge leap with apple
silicon processors compared to the
previous intel models now as far as real
world performance and snappiness we use
speedometer 2.0 and man does it show a
huge difference that 3.2 gigahertz xeon
in the imac pro is really slow it's
clocked quite low as far as multi-core
performance we once again have a massive
leap and not only with the m1 ultra
which is about two and a half times
faster than the i9 intel model
but also even with the base m1 max model
for two grand that's about 35 percent
faster than the i9 of course the xeon
has a older processor it is slower and
if you have the 10 core imac
then that is actually close to this i9
in the regular imac now as far as
graphics three of these macs are very
close in terms of performance so you see
if you have an imac pro even the base
2000 max studio performs very similarly
slightly better actually and of course
the ultra does stand out now this
geekbench 5 metal test doesn't scale
very well there's a lot of times where
the m1 max and ultra are just sitting
there waiting for instructions so when
we take a look at a program like gfx
bench which is very well optimized we
start to see the improvements with the
apple silicon graphics compared to the
previous amd so this has given us a
little hint as to what we can expect
with applications that are optimized now
when we max out the cpus in cinebench
the most powerful intel i9 imac actually
slightly outscores the m1 max but of
course that one ultra has double the
cores
and that thing is insanely fast
basically twice as fast so really good
cpu performance now on top of these
differences we also have differences in
terms of the amount of power that's
required to get this performance so our
m1 max only uses about 28 watts to get
that score compared to the i9 imac which
uses 159
and the m1 ultra gets double the
performance while using almost three
times less power and here's the score
per watt breakdown for you it's a
dramatic difference these apple silicon
processors are so efficient and now with
these performance numbers let's jump
into real world tasks now uh the first
thing i want to show you guys is just
the ssd so you guys know ahead of time
that says ssds in these new systems are
about twice as fast as well so that is
great for most of these tests it does
not make a difference maybe just in the
lightroom test which is also another
difference but i want to start out with
xcode here and dang do we have a
difference now you see that the m1 ultra
isn't that much faster than the m1 max
even though it has a lot more cores
that's just because a lot of this
performance is because of the efficiency
of unified memory but jumping from any
imac to mac studio for coding is going
to give you a huge improvement in
performance now as far as logic we have
our new logic pro benchmark you can look
it up exactly what we test here and the
m1 max does outperform even the imac pro
so really good gains there and then of
course if you need a lot more
performance in ram you can go with the
ultra and kick up to 128 gigs ours only
has 64. now this is where i want to let
you guys know that we also have a triple
comparison between both of these mac
studios and the highest end one we go
into a ton of detail so if you guys want
to see that we'll leave a little end
card at the end of this video now as far
as photo editing i tested out three
different applications i'm going to
start with affinity and i want to show
you guys out there some of you guys that
complain and saying hey you know the
graphics isn't that much better in
geekbench well take a look at these gpu
performance numbers we go from 21 000 on
the best imac ever which was already 6
000 above the imac pro to 27 000 and
then up to 45 000 score for the m1 ultra
these are huge improvements in real
world gpu processing which is what most
of affinity uses now as far as the cpu
which is used for vector items you guys
could see that the mac studios don't
have that much of a difference but
they're both quite a bit faster than the
intel imac so even though the cpu
differences even with that base model
max studio doesn't seem like a lot in
benchmarks real world it's a big jump
now as far as lightroom classic the
editing performance is snappier brushes
zooming in switching and as far as
exporting these 500 raw images you guys
see my goodness we go from 22 and a half
minutes down to 13 minutes and 40
seconds on the 2 000 base max studio um
that is a huge jump now why is the imac
actually slower than imac pro well
because the imac has dual channel memory
compared to quad channel with that imac
pro which really helped it out even
though mac pro has half the ram now with
the same amount of ram with the m1 max i
believe it's using like 16 channel or 30
it's just insane the amount of bandwidth
that it has so our export is much faster
but then the m1 ultra you guys see seven
minutes and 30 seconds for 500 raw
edited 42 megapixel images that is
insane performance so if you're somebody
who does photos you're working with
lightroom especially if you're working
for waiting for things like hdr
panoramas man these machines are so fast
and it will make some people that i know
another thousand dollars to 1500 a month
just being able to take on more editing
work because you're not sitting there
waiting it is crazy now as far as
photoshop
i went ahead and did this auto merge
which is a 16 photos 50 megapixel raw
panorama and stitching everything
together blending it you guys see the
performance difference right there it is
pretty dramatic and then the same thing
goes for puget bench which we ran which
tests out the whole you know a ton of
different tests in photoshop so great
improvements now many of you guys asked
about after effects and i don't use
after effects so we typically don't test
it but i also use puja benz just
benchmark which tests a bunch of things
you guys could see that the 2000 m1 max
is about 25 faster than the imac so that
is a good improvement depending you know
if you're looking at price points and
stuff and then if you jump up to the
ultra the 4 000 when it's a 75
improvement and bigger compared to the
imac pro uh so if you're using after
effects we're definitely seeing some
nice performance boost even though it's
not yet fully optimized at least for the
unified memory and the tile memory now
for 3d work with blender we tested out
the latest release which does use metal
graphics and you'll see that the
performance difference isn't massive uh
the m1 max 2000 one is a little bit
faster than the other graphics cards but
not by much and then the ultra is also
faster also not a big difference now
this just proves that even though
blender now supports metal to use the
graphics it does not mean that it is
optimized for the apple silicon chips
it's not using the unified memory uh
special improvements it's not using the
tile memory meaning it's instead of
running a full efficiency and keeping
all the frames in the gpu it's still
riding back and forth just like with the
intel based system so that means that in
the future when blender is updated it's
going to get a lot faster now let's jump
into video editing i have a couple tests
in resolve also final cut now for
editing your standard h264 footage the
performance is very very similar but the
exports are you know close to about i
don't know 75 faster close to twice as
fast so that is nice but if you're just
working with basic footage i would not
want to upgrade now if you're working
with h.265
man things get a lot faster i mean we're
looking at more than three times faster
here in terms of exports now with that
as far as timeline smoothness
also not a huge difference unless you're
stacking tons of effects or unless
you're doing a bunch of 4k multicam
because these mac studios have extra
decoders that means that it can handle
more streams of footage so if you
struggle with that it's going to be a
nice improvement for you now let's get
into some really tough tests that really
push the raw graphics performance and
don't really focus on exporting speeds
or those encoders i went ahead and
tested out this blackmagic raw
de-noising it's very tough i have
multiple layers of spatial and temporal
noise reduction in our imax play this
back at 11 and 12 frames per second out
of the 24
with the limitation being just the
graphics now the 2 000 mac studio it
runs at 12 frames per second again so
it's very close so if you're really
pushing the gpu and that's your
limitation you definitely want to go for
the ultra that is at 16. now this is one
of the few tasks that are fully
optimized and fully graphics limited
where i would say spend the extra
thousand dollars on the 64 core ultra
which gets you to 20. in most other
things that jump is not really worth it
now we also tested out ak red raw this
is with film grain and with color
corrections and luts and our 4 000 max
studio was basically twice as fast in
terms of exporting compared to the i9
imac and also in terms of playback it
also had a good boost in performance now
if you have the previous imac and you're
thinking about going for a 2 000 one
this is once again here where you don't
have a big jump in raw graphics
performance and i think where we have
the biggest gains is prores because the
max studios have dedicated pro as
decoders and encoders in my mac pro we
had to get a two thousand dollar card to
help with prores this is just built in
even to the base two thousand dollar
model now here you see with 4k prores
raw going to pro res our 2 000 model is
more than three times faster than the
imac and more than five times faster
than the imac pro it's a massive
difference the same thing goes for
playback and multicam it is huge now
when we switch over to 8k this is also
with luts and color corrections we just
see a dramatic difference in performance
it is insane so if you're somebody that
works with prores and you want better
performance this is the way to go
because of the decoders they can handle
the footage you have a lot more
performance both on cpu and gpu to be
able to handle effects titles anything
like that so there you guys go as far as
raw graphics performance and things
where we're just limited there we don't
see a massive upgrade unless you're
willing to spend you know a good amount
of money in that case yes you are
spending more this time around if you
have to buy a display keyboard mouse uh
compared to before but in most other
tests especially the cpu tests and the
ones that are optimized
you can buy a 2 000 model and then get a
screen and whatever you want if you
previously spent five thousand dollars
on your um your imac or imac pro so you
technically are getting more performance
for a lower price and then if you need
even more than that you have the option
to spend more so for those you guys that
are waiting to upgrade you're thinking
wondering if this is worth it well there
you guys go you see the real world
results and you guys can make up the
choice for yourself
i think these are great machines and of
course we have the difference in ports
as well where the imac that we
recommended only had two thunderbolt
ports uh and this one you can either get
four with two usbcs or you can get eight
so we have a lot of poor options as well
and that is nice and also we're not
missing out on the sd card so really
really nice upgrade for those of you
guys that have imacs thank you guys for
watching check out our triple comparison
right over there and that other great
video click above to subscribe to help
us reach our goal of one million
subscribers we'd greatly appreciate it
that's been max and i'll see you in the
next video
[Music]